question asking is a very valuable skill
to develop but what makes for a good
question join me in this best of episode
where I speak with Deborah schiffrin
about question asking and the value of a
good question I was particularly
fascinated by Deborah's suggestion about
using values as a critical component to
making good
questions
what is one of the most versatile
communication tools everyone should have
in their toolkits the answer is asking
questions I think questions are the
Swiss army knife of communication a
well-timed question can accomplish
Myriad communication tasks from building
trust and understanding to fostering
engagement and calming your nerves
through asking good questions you can
become a more connected and authentic
communicator
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stamford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast today
I am super excited to have Deborah
schiffren Here Deborah is a lecturer at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
where she teaches two MBA courses she
co-created spontaneous management and
creativity in the business ecosystem
prior to joining Stamford Deborah spent
a decade as a national public radio
reporter producer and director welcome
Deborah I love collaborating with you
and I look forward to our chat me too
let's get started why questions what do
they do for us there's a range of goals
and purposes we have for asking
questions of course the big one is
getting information Matt what time is it
uh it's a little bit before noon
actually so that that's how that works I
needed information I asked Matt and I
got the information I needed but the
second one is building relationships so
you want to use it to build
relationships you ask people questions
you get to know about them they get to
know about you and then there's other
goals you can use in the workplace you
can ask questions to generate ideas and
Foster
creativity then of course it's are
darker goals like interrogate or
intimidate or avoid
responsibility
I think I'll take one Matt if it's okay
and break it down a little bit oh
absolutely I'd love to hear more so one
of the big ones I mentioned was building
relationships so if you're asking
questions you're signaling to the other
person that you value them you're taking
time to listen to their answers you're
telling them that their answers matter
and they
matter and the other one that I think is
really important is the type of question
that comes with coaching or mentoring
people and a lot of people are mentors a
lot of leaders are mentors to younger
people coming up in the organization for
me I use it mostly in my coaching
practice and I'll give you two examples
which I love imagine I'm talking to
someone and they are deciding whether to
take a job offer we'll be talking and
we'll be weighing the pros and cons
right and then I'll stop them and I'll
say what do you want
and it's sort of a disruptive question
it Raks the back and forth between the
Tactical decisions and it just takes
things up to another level a second one
is say someone is telling me they're
feeling inadequate when I hear that a
couple times I will say how is feeling
inadequate serving you and what is it
costing you and it really makes people
stop and think about it how is it
supporting me and how is it harming me
and it makes people either take action
to change it or change their
mindset I see you know a key takeaway I
I had from what you just said is it's
it's not just the question you ask but
it's the willingness to actually ask the
question in the first place and then
listen to the answer that's what can
really help disrupt the conversation or
show that you you really are concerned
with the person and want to Foster that
connection is that right yes absolutely
and you have to have some sort of trust
up so this isn't a question you're not
going to meet someone for the first time
and say Matt what do you want but if you
have a relationship with someone of some
sort with us some trust then you can
start using those questions clearly
questions can help us achieve many ends
that are positive and pro-social but you
did mention that goals were not always
as friendly such as intimidation and
avoiding responsibility can you talk
more about these yes I can I'll mention
interrogating so this is another way to
get information I suppose but you're
doing it in a very unpleasant way you
might try to trap someone into making a
mistake or doing a gotcha question so
that's not very pleasant people can use
questions to intimidate and a lot of
times that has to do with power dynamics
so they may want to use a question to
increase their power dynamic or take
advantage of a power Dynamic that
already exists and a third one is
avoiding responsibility so
this brings me back to my improv
training days many years ago when I was
learning and we are told as improvisers
not to ask questions on stage and it may
seem
counterintuitive but the reason is say
you and I are in a scene and we're both
creating it together there's no script
so we're going back and forth and
building something and if I keep asking
you questions you have to do all the
work to come up with all the ideas you
don't want to do that you want to share
the bird and there's an example that I
think most people can relate to so Matt
say we were going to go to a movie and
we were trying to figure out where to go
to dinner I say there's like five of us
and someone would say hey where do you
want to go for dinner and the next
person will say I don't know where do
you want to go for dinner that could go
to all five people you you I think
you're describing my entire teenage
years I think that's what we did every
Friday and Saturday night believe me I'm
so Happ to me now I'm in San Francisco
and there's so many options but I think
the reason that happens eventually
someone will step up and suggest an
actual restaurant but I think that
happens because one people might not
want to take the responsibility of
choosing the restaurant but I think also
people are afraid that if they pick a
restaurant and the rest of the group
doesn't end up liking the food that
they're somehow responsible for that so
it is an avoiding responsibility
technique talk to me a little bit about
how tone plays out in question asking
tone is really important tone can turn
question negative or positive the same
question all right Matt let's do a role
play okay I'm ready you ready okay so
Matt you're gonna be the employee and
I'm gonna be the manager see how I did
that yes ma'am all right so Matt this is
your line and I will respond two ways
you'll say the line I'll respond you'll
say the line I'll respond again so Matt
your line is I have a plan to automate
customer service all right I have a plan
to automate customer service what do you
think it will take to implement that
plan are generally supportive mhm say it
again I have a plan to automate customer
service what do you think it'll take to
implement that plan oh wow that's very
different different just emphasize one
word that and it changeed the entire
tone and context of the meaning so your
point Deborah is very clear tone really
does matter in question asking and I
would argue in in most
communication having this conversation
with you has helped me realize that we
can get better answers if we ask better
questions so what goes into a good
question I like to use words that are
related to values words like impact an
example would be Matt how does your
decision impact yourself and the
organization mhm yeah something like
Matt what's important or what's at
State and one that I love is say at the
end of a project and I'll say to you Ma
what can we create from here what can we
create from here and that just assumes
that people are
creative and once that's assumed people
rise to the occasion and they free
themselves to make suggestions they
might not otherwise
made I really like that I I I like
positioning the person uh in the
conversation in a very different
perspective through the question that
you ask oh can I add one more thing you
sure can when the project is over people
often forget to ask questions that will
get a catalog of what we well still of
the to succeed how did your team
accomplish the task so when it's all
said and done you got the project make
sure you ask what went
well I love your list of questions uh
it's about open questions not Clos
questions it's about asking people to
reflect and really think about the
experience they had what it felt like
what they learned from it how they can
apply it thinking about impactful words
you like how I did that I used one of
your impactful words as and then well
done and then making sure that you ask
questions about when a project is
complete that that that's a fantastic
advice advice for for good questions to
ask speaking of advice what advice would
you give to Business Leaders regarding
question asking whether you're a leader
or anywhere in the organization it takes
some bravery to ask questions if you
don't know what the answer will be as
adults it's scary kids ask a lot of
questions yes they do what color is the
moon and you know when's dinner but
adults don't ask as many questions
because it's a little scary you're
handing the control of the conversation
to someone else and you have this fear
that it could harm your psyche in subm
my advice is to leave time for questions
and be open to the answers ones that you
want to hear or answers that you don't
want to hear and then Express how much
meeting time you spend asking versus
telling people what to do so inquiry
versus
statements that last uh point about uh
speaking time and and how they're
allocated versus inquiry or statements
we've heard that before when Bob Sutton
was on the podcast we spent a little bit
about it and and he said from his
perspective in his research he's found
that leaders who ask more questions uh
are perceived as better leaders have
better data to make decisions and
actually people like them more so
there's a whole lot of value to
following the advice of making sure to
leave time for questions uh be opening
to be open to the answers and then pay
attention to how much time you're you're
ask actually asking questions versus uh
just making statements so thank you for
that uh really important
advice now you've done a lot of question
asking throughout your life as a
reporter as a coach and a teacher what
are some best practices for question
asking and does the context matter yes
the context definitely matters you have
to know who's in the room what their
agendas are what their needs are so
that's something you have to figure out
before you figure out the question or
even the type of question you want to
ask in terms of best practices I'll
frame it this way I feel like a lot of
best practices stem from a mindset of
curiosity so if I were interviewing you
Matt but this not just for interviewing
but if I were an NPR reporter like I was
interviewing you and you say something
that surprises me or has emotional
charge I want to follow up on that and
ask you another question sure I've come
with my list of 10 questions to ask you
those questions but I don't have to
stick to that script I can just go off
script and come back what I do as a
journalist is I have my Miss but I say
in advance these three questions I
absolutely need answers to but the rest
if I hear something interesting I go for
it that's really really interesting so
if you take time to listen thoroughly
and ask questions you can actually learn
a lot more information when you think
about being curious you're listening for
information that's interesting and
surprising but you're also in a state
where you're curious about the other
person and you're not just asking them
questions from your own frame of
reference Matt if I were interviewing
you oh who would want to do questions
that Delight or engage you or questions
you may not have thought about before so
uh here's an example I was my brother's
house and he had a friend over who was a
physicist he worked at UC Berkeley as a
post do so I thought oh I'm interested
in physics but I don't know much but I
know something I'll ask him the question
that I know so I said are you a
theoretical physicist or an applied
physicist he answered the question it
was okay question but he didn't get very
excited about it so then I thought for a
minute and I asked him what's something
surprising that happened for you this
year and suddenly he lit up he got so
animated he was talking about these
things that he had done in his lab and
he was picking up things on the table
like a cup or a plate and showing me how
Mass works by using these the cup and
the and the plate and so at the end I
found out that he discovered something
pretty cool it was connecting
mathematics to a particle that
scientists think is related to Dark
Matter so of course I can't understand
the full scope of what that means not
being a physicist but it was pretty
amazing and if I hadn't asked that
question it that never would have
happened wow so again it's it's being
curious and and really thinking about
how to help how how to put the other
person in a position where they can can
share an answer that's really meaningful
for them yeah and I would say this is
good for leaders as well when you ask
someone a question ask them a question
that enables them to speak from their
perspective so ask those open questions
give them a chance to speak from their
base of knowledge and not what they
think you want them to say based on your
frame of knowledge ah excellent way to
summarize that let me ask you this do
you have a secret weapon or trick up
your sleeve that you use to get to
insightful and uh surprising
responses I do I call it the killer last
question oo tell me more and I'll have
to tell you what it is and how you ask
it that's a very important part there's
several
steps I'm talking with someone and we've
had a conversation we've buil were poor
and it's time to end the conversation or
the interview so I say to them is there
anything I didn't ask you that you think
is important and then here's the next
step and this is really
important I had to wait have can wait in
silence and be comfortable with the
silence and then nine out of 10 times
the person says I don't think so but
then you wait
again another it could be like eight
seconds and then they will say the most
interesting thing that they said in the
whole
interview and I think this happens
because you are turning the control over
to them you're handing them the mic you
are putting them in the driver seat and
so it creates a condition where they're
more likely to share something or at the
end of this conversation we've been
talking about a lot of things it lets
them ask a question of themselves and
get to an answer so something they're
excited
about you know it's interesting that you
bring that technique up of waiting
because uh waiting is something I always
coach people to do people don't like
that awkward pause so they'll ask a
question and if nobody responds
immediately then they'll just move on
right I had never really thought of that
pause allowing people to really do some
self-reflection and really having that
be an opportunity for people to to dig
deeper and provide uh more information
or disclose something that's that's a
little more personal so I really like
that let's do an experiment for our
listeners I asking a question that
you've never heard right you don't know
what I'm gonna say I have no idea I'm
locked in this cone of silence and then
ask it to you once and then I'll ask it
in a different way and see how the
results change all right so I'm going to
answer it twice go for it yes here's the
first question today's podcast will be
really great
right absolutely this should be a great
podcast let me ask it in a different
way what is important to you about
today's
podcast I so much hope that people
listen to your passion for asking
questions to really Bond and build on
relationships people have that I hope
when people are done listening that they
feel they have the tools and the energy
to go do what you
do so those are the two questions so you
can see the difference the first
question the way I asked it I didn't get
any
information um and then did did you feel
a little bit pigeon hold I think one one
there really was only one answer what
what am I going to say
right totally but the second question
really allowed me to to give insight
into the the work that I did and you did
in preparation for this and really let
people know that we really want people
to take good value from what it is we do
so I totally appreciate the difference
and I can see why you are a good
question asker so so thank you for that
now this whole time we've talked today
Deborah has been about questions and
answering would you indul me and answer
the three questions that I ask of all of
our guests at the end of our podcast
absolutely if you listen to the answers
I'll tell you anything I will absolutely
listen question number one if you were
to capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to
seven-word presentation slide title what
would that
be be present and build on others
ideas this this is the Improv wisdom
that's come down decades and decades to
me today and to the people I'm teaching
excellent thank you let me ask you
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and
why I'm really interested by comma
Harris right now she is very calm at the
same time she's very passionate it's a
great combination and she owns the r a
lot of politicians are very stiff mhm if
she's not she moves but she moves with
purpose so when she moves there's a
reason and it's very clear and the worst
thing about her is that she has mastered
the smile for All Occasions she has the
right smile for whether she's debating
Mike Pence or introducing Joe Biden she
has the right smile and smiling can be
really tricky for women tell me more
about smiling and and the the challenges
involved in that
I've seen a lot of women be given the
communication advice to smile
more and I think it's really
undermining because we know what we want
to say and how we want to say it and for
giv the advice smile more essentially
we're being told to be nicer to seem
more pleasant to even be more feminine
and those can be really undermining
messages and I see it all the time so
sometimes as a woman it's hard to
remember that you own your smile you own
your presentation and that you should do
what's best for
you absolutely
absolutely let me ask question number
three what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication
recipe I want to go back to again be
present and I'll tell you a little bit
more about why it keeps you grounded it
connects you to your audience of one or
a thousand and it keeps that inner
critic that judge away from you we all
have that critic that right now say I'm
talking to you I am thinking about what
I said just a minute ago and judging it
was that stupid and then right now I'm
talking to you and I might if I a judge
I might be judging myself what I'm
saying right now is stupid and then
we'll move on to the next question I'm
not listening because I'm thinking about
the stupid thing I said a moment go that
right that judge is really powerful and
if we can be present we can move that
judge out of the way that's number one
mhm number two I would say rigorously
prepare but be ready to go off script
you need both of those pieces you have
you really have to prepare I know you've
said this in the past also that there's
no subit for Preparation but you need to
be ready to go off script lead with
energy and commitment to the audience
if you do that you will engage your
audience they see that you want to be
there that you're excited to be there
and that you are there for them 100% and
when you do that it will give you more
confidence and confidence will improve
your credibility in front of your
audience I really like your recipe a lot
being present and prepar preparing but
being willing to to go with what's
needed in the moment uh really powerful
and then of course being audience
centered and and doing so in an
energetic way will help you know Deborah
thank you so much uh as we wrap up I
find myself asking a question what are
my takeaways from today and and the
answer is abundantly clear questions can
really help our communication by taking
the time to plan our questions and
actively listen to the answers we can
build camaraderie and closeness and
ultimately improve our communication
thank you so much for your time and for
your Insight it's been my
pleasure thank you for listening to
think fast talk smart the podcast a
production of Stanford Graduate School
of Business to learn more go to gb.
stanford.edu please download other
episodes wherever you find your
podcast